hey let's get back to Chris Wallace and
FoxNews for a moment we have this idea
that we've seen many times where every
once in a while we hear some sense from
Fox News and when we do it's almost
always shepard smith but sometimes it's
chris wallace today it's chris wallace
another piece of that interview that i
told you about earlier between chris
wallace and donald trump that aired
yesterday relates to the perception of
Trump around the world as an oppressor
and it's not really clear to us whether
Trump knows that he's seen around the
world as a guy who oppresses free speech
and depresses freedom of the press and
is extraordinarily authoritarian in his
tendencies and I wonder that because we
know that Trump mostly watches fox news
but particularly during the friendly
hours which are most of them including
Sean Hannity and Fox and Friends
we know that Trump gets a twice a day
propaganda file and Chris Wallace in
this interview goes directly at Trump
about his attacks on media and he went
even further to say that Trump is seen
as a beacon of repression around the
world I really like this confronting
Trump with this and of course from
doesn't care or doesn't believe it but
it's still good to see starting with
Trump starts with no one believes in the
First Amendment more than him just like
he once said no one respects women more
than him remember that nobody believes
in the First Amendment more than I do
and if I think somebody's acting out of
sorts
I will leave I'll say thank you very
much everybody I appreciate you coming
and I'll leave and those reporters will
not be too friendly to whoever it is
that's acting up why didn't you call on
Acosta in the first place I mean it
seems to me there's a simple solution
here just don't call it actually I like
to do it but in many cases I don't he'll
stand up he's unbelievably rude to Sarah
Huckabee who's a wonderful woman
unbelievably rude and I see that and I
actually asked her the same why do you
call them these people that are so nasty
and I think one of the things we'll do
is maybe turn the camera off that faces
them because then they don't have any
airtime although I'll probably be sued
for that and maybe
you know win or lose and who knows I
mean with with this stuff you never know
what's gonna happen yeah okay so then we
get into the real meat of it and here
Trump also says that his supporters are
just so smart such smart people let's
get to the bigger issue in 2017 last
year you tweeted this and I want to
quote it accurately the fake news media
is not my enemy it is the enemy of the
American people's true 100% not the
media I'm glad you're finally quoting it
correctly because they like to leave the
fake news okay but that's what Yusef ake
News so but people that are supporting
me in particular they have very smart
people they're hard-working brilliant
great people they know when the news is
fake and they get angry when they see
all of the fake but it said frankly than
people who've been critical of other
presidents they're there no president
has liked his press coverage so then we
get to the confrontation Chris Wallace
saying to Trump you are seen as a beacon
of repression pay close attention to
what Donald Trump says cert leaders in
authoritarian countries like Russia
China Venezuela now repress the media
using your words I can't talk for other
people I can only talk for me I will
tell you if you're sitting around the
world listen for a session not to work
I'm not talking about you but you
sometimes maybe but I'm not talking
about you
the news about me is largely phony it's
false even sometimes they'll say sources
say there is no source in many cases in
many cases there is I understand you
don't like second can I just bring the
bigger 84% I bring the bigger issue up
yeah bill McRaven retired Admiral Navy
SEAL 37 years former head of US Special
Operations Linton fan special operation
has made Hillary Clinton fan who led the
operations commanded the operations that
took down Sodom insane and they killed
Osama bin Laden says that your sentiment
is the greatest threat to democracy in
his life he's a Hillary Clinton
Becker and an Obama backer and Franklin
Avco nice if we got Osama bin Laden a
lot sooner than that and there it is the
leader of the raid to get bin Laden and
Saddam you could be against doing those
things but this is no bleeding-heart
liberal and trump immediately discredits
him and says why didn't we get bin Laden
sooner as if that would even have been
up to this particular member of the
military and there's a good thing that
chris wallace does here
he doesn't concede when trump says that
the news is fake Trump keeps repeating
that Chris Wallace says I understand you
don't like the coverage he doesn't even
concede or appear to concede that and
Trump does sort of appear to keep his
cool but he was not at all pleased with
this exchange at all and the real reason
that this is so damaging to Trump is
that first of all it's on Fox News yes
the Fox News audience is already calling
for Chris Wallace to be fired like they
do with Shep Smith every time he tells
the truth but this is removing the idea
that Trump is in this for anybody but
himself his inability to accept
criticism the way he reacts to every
question that's remotely critical is to
attack other people Jim Acosta says
Chris Wallace Acosta's a lying terrible
fake news reporter who's rude to me
Trump says which is not an argument the
guy who got bin Laden but that's a
Hillary Clinton backer and why didn't he
get bin Laden any sooner the world sees
you as the beacon of repression even our
most decorated military well those
people don't know what they're talking
about because they backed Hillary you
were seeing the unraveling of a very
unwell person someone with yes serious
personality disorders but it's really
important not to mistake confidence for
competence Trump has maintained support
to the degree that he has from his
followers not because of competence but
because his confidence his ability to
sound confident every time he opens his
mouth when he's asked critical questions
are what appeals to is what appeals to
his supporters even though when you
actually listen to the words you realize
that there's
no competence whatsoever send me your
thoughts we will post clips from today's
show on instagram at david pakman show
follow me on instagram at david pakman
as well quick break back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by movement founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank
movement watches are all about looking
good while keeping it simple they don't
tell you how many steps you've taken
they don't allow you to get text
messages on your wrist
they tell time like timepieces should
I've had such great experience with my
to movement watches which I've now had
for a couple of years everywhere I go
people are looking down at my wrists
saying well where'd you get that watch
and they start at just ninety five
dollars meanwhile you'd be looking at
four to five hundred dollars for the
same quality from a traditional brand no
wonder that movement has sold almost two
million watches in more than 160
countries if you need some help giving
the perfect gift this season but don't
know where to start I highly recommend
you check out what the guys over at
movement have they did all the hard work
by curating their favorite styles into
really great gift boxes and packages so
that you wouldn't have to you can get
15% off today with free shipping free
returns by going to MVM t-dot-com slash
Pakman they're not launching new styles
on their website all the time including
a lot of really good ones check out
their latest at MVM t.com slash Pakman
that is MVM decom /pa KMA n join the
movement